In this tutorial, we're going to make
realistic fur. And I'm not talking about
that hair particle system nonsense.
Here's the algorithm. I'm going to start
off with a spiral that I'm going to
shape, create some duplicates with some
variation, maybe make a few copies of
these that are, you know, slightly
different from each other on our object.
I'm going to distribute a bunch of
points. And then I'm going to instance
our thing on that. Make it look good
with a material. That's it. So, let me
show you how to do that. And this video
is sponsored by Squarespace, and we'll
talk about that later. In geometry
nodes, we're going to start off with a
spiral using a spiral node. This spiral
should look more like this. Kind of like
a unclosed circle. I'm going to bring
down the height. Bring down the rotation
until it's roughly what I want. From the
top view, it should be pinching as it
grows out. So, bring down the end radius
until it looks something like that. I
want there to be like instances that are
slightly varied. Some of them are short,
some of them are long, and it's going to
be distorted. To do this, I'm going to
make some variations. So, I'm going to
have points. Let's say I have 10 of
these. And then for each of these 10
points, not instances, for each,
separate out the point. Inside of here
is where we're going to put our spiral
so that we can kind of give this
different settings. So you can see here
we have 10 splines or we could have 15
or you know whatever it is. Each one
needs to be slightly offseted and we can
treat that by like picking a different
start and end radius. For each of these
I'm going to pick a random value. In
fact, I'm going to pick a single random
value. This node right here that doesn't
come in default blender you can get for
free from my node pack. So literally
cggatter.com go to free nodes and you
can download an add-on that will let you
refresh my node pack every time I update
it. That will just give you free nodes.
Lets me make the videos faster. This
single random value is going to be
dependent on the current index. So for
each of the 10 of these, we're going to
have a random number like 0.12 whatever
it may be. This I want to connect to the
start radius. And all of the sudden we
have these variations. Since the default
value is roughly one, let's vary this
from like.5 to 1.5. And to vary kind of
the curvature of this cuz they're
perfectly aligned. We need some of them
to coil more than others. And this is
great cuz I can again use a single
random value. And rotations is hovering
around like 8. So let's go from 0.5 to
like 1.2 2. Connect that to rotations
and now they're kind of different from
each other. Additionally, the height,
how far off the surface it goes, can
also be randomized. So, just a bunch of
random values 2 to 1. Connect that to
the height. Another way we can randomize
is this end radius. How much does it
pinch at the end? And I do want it to
pinch quite a bit. So, single random
value connected to the end radius, which
is around 6.3 to 7. Last of all, I'm
going to trim the curve, which is going
to let me, you know, do this. And this
will let me make some hairs longer or
shorter than others. random value with
this index halfway.5 all the way to one.
Connect that here. So essentially what
we've done now is we've made like a
custom curl generator basically. And as
a final kind of hit of detail, we should
probably distort this. Use the distort
node again from cdgatter.com. That will
give you this. I'm going to bring down
the strength to like 10%. Bring down the
scale so it's lower frequency detail.
And you can see right now the noise is
kind of continuous. They're bunching and
doing this kind of together. I want them
to behave more separately. I can do this
by taking the coordinates of the
distortion which basically tells you
where should this like noise be mapped
to. You can use this kind of like as a
randomization seed. So why don't we take
the index one more time connected here.
Now they all act independently and you
pick some numbers that feel right to
you. And this can be considered one hair
spiral. When we're done with it we'll do
one final resampling to I don't know it
shouldn't be too much. Maybe like 60
iterations. We can turn it into geometry
cuz this is essentially a bunch of
curves. Run a curve to mesh. And then
what do we mesh it by? Maybe like a
curved circle set to a low resolution
like three. Bring down the scale to
something where you can see the
individual hair strands. And then let's
just give it many many more iterations
like 30. This is a single hair clump.
I'm going to take all of this, turn it
into a node group, maybe like literally
everything. Ctrl G. And this can be
considered our clump or whatever. Our
clump should have some exposed
parameters. I want to know how many
points make up the clump. I probably
want to have a control of the seed in
general, which I can offset by just like
adding a number like 1 2 3 whatever. So
that should be a parameter. And then
maybe we can make one more offset. Maybe
something like the end radius, which
ends up making it look quite different.
So I'm going to add one more
contribution. This is going to be our
end radius. Maybe one more parameter we
might want to control is the strength.
Very easy to do. I'm just going to
expose the strength vector. And there we
go. This is our node group with
parameters basically. So I could change
the number of hairs. I can change the
end radius. And now we have a way to
make our clumps distinct. Speaking of
which, let's make three different
variations. Or you can make however many
you want. The second one might pinch to
a smaller number, have fewer hairs, a
bit less distortion since it's more
clumped together, and definitely a
different seed. The final clump,
different seed for sure, extra hairs, a
little pinched, and then extra
distortion maybe. So now we have three
different clumps that all look different
from each other. And when we instance
them, you will not be able to see the
pattern as much. I'm going to treat each
of these as a instance, which will help
with our instancing. Geometry to
instance. I want each of these to be
separate. And then I just join them
together so that we have a collection in
the sense of three instances. Right here
we have three different instances with
different parameters. Super simple to
interpret. Then on my initial geometry,
don't forget we have like a cube or
whatever here. Let's in fact make it a
very smooth sphere. I want to distribute
a bunch of points on the faces. So we
get something like this. Each one's
going to represent a clump. We'll make
this super dense. And then I'm going to
instance on these points for each one
one of these three variants. Plug this
into the instance. And then make sure
you have pick instance enabled. This
will let you pick one of the three each
time. Finally, we we need to take this
nonsense over here and make it actually
legible. One way to do that is you take
the scale and bring it down until you
can see the actual clumps. And you can
see it's starting to look quite soft.
This should be a randomized value so
that it's not always the same size.
Let's go from 03 to 008 and make that
the scale. So now they're not all all
the same size. And then finally to get
them going off of the surface normal, so
they're kind of pointing off of the skin
and it's like fur. Take the rotation,
make it the rotation. And just like
that, we have furiness. Very good. Very
good. bring up the density quite a lot.
Don't be shy to make it like 300 or even
a thousand. Let's join everything
together. So, we have our initial
surface plus all these instances that
gets joined. And now we have a good
basis to work off of. It's much more
legible when it's shaded with cycles or
whatever. Cycles GPU. I'm using Blender
for or no, I'm using Blender 5.0. That's
the important part, which has a very
nice sky texture update with multiple
scattering. Connect that there. Pick
some settings that actually make this
visible. And now you can kind of tell we
have the basis for our fur. And it's not
looking too bad, but we can make it look
a whole lot better. This is the part
where I tell you this video is sponsored
by Squarespace. This is the service I
used to make my website. You can go to
cgmatter.com, go to free nodes, and get
the nodes that I'm using. And because
I'm using Squarespace to build and host
this website, it comes with a lot of
features. So here you can see my
Squarespace UI. First of all, it comes
with a content and membership section.
So I literally sell my project files,
including this one. That's possible
because of Squarespace payments that let
you pay directly without integrating
something else. Second of all, you're
going to see I have these assets over
here, which I use throughout the
website. get all kinds of gifts and
stuff you might recognize from earlier
posts. I like this cuz I can keep
everything in one place. Finally, at
this point, Squarespace has tightlyknit
AI integration, which you can use to
fill content, use for design, whatever.
I can edit, add a section, add a block,
like a text block or whatever you want
it to be. And then in here, when I edit,
you're going to see this little UI right
here. And let's write a paragraph about
what is new in Blender 5.0. Okay, it
took a second to think and now it is
filling all of our content, which you
can then check, say, oh, I want to edit
this part, whatever. So, if you're
looking to build a website, try it out.
And when you're ready to take your
website and you want to launch it, make
it live, you can use this link in the
description to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain. So,
now we have this fur that our goal is to
make it look better, but it's already
part of the way there. I think a big
step for this is taking this wool and
particularly these like spirals that
make up the instances and we need to
randomize it where we can. So, for
example, the rotation, I can add a
random contribution. So, I'm going to
rotate the rotation. It turns out one of
the new nodes is random rotation or you
can use my custom one, whichever one
feels easier. I'm just going to use my
own. Connect that right there. Bring
down the strength until it's like 10%
randomized. I believe you also want to
make this in local space just so it
rotates about the normal. And inside
this node, which right now is packed,
what I can do is I can unpack this uh by
hitting that button I just hit. Go
inside of here and instead of a random
value that turns out to be a vector that
I then scale by like a float, I'm just
going to make a tiny modification. I'm
going to make this multiply. So I can
control XYZ and I can modify the
strength to be a vector. Connect this
back here. This is useful because is it
the Z component? The Z component just
rotates it about its own axis. And that
can be as big as I want. It can be like
100. And then for the X and Y that kind
of messes it up, but if it's subtle,
it's good. I can pick some low numbers
that do not mess it up. So before,
after. Finally, I probably want some of
these hair strands to kind of go taller
than they were before. So for the random
scale, I like 03 to 008, but I can make
that a vector. that goes from 003 to
008. So it's exactly the same, but I can
make the Z variation much bigger. So
some of them get higher than the others,
just subtly. And this will make it look
more like it's being grown off of a
surface. Consolidate nodes where you
can, where you know you're not going to
be editing anything. All of this looks
great to me. And let's see what this
looks like. Pretty good. And we haven't
even done the shaders or anything yet.
Before I do that, I'm just going to up
the iteration so it better covers the
surface. And it will render quite
quickly. So not bad at all. And I
probably want to add one more pass of
detail so that it doesn't exactly look
like instances everywhere. To do that, I
need to take these instances and I'm
going to realize them so that they're
actual geometry. This is going to take a
moment to compute. So what I would
recommend is add a bake node which will
let you do this calculation once and
then save it. So let's bake on frame
one. So now this is on disk or packed
into your Blender file. Replace that
connection over here so that it's using
it. And then finally, I want to take
this and apply like a distortion or
whatever. So I'm going to use my distort
node again. Make that bad boy way
tinier. So maybe like a fifth of a
percent or half a percent, I mean. And
then I'm going to add a detail to that.
So of course you can play with this
more, but I think that's a pretty good
start to get like soft looking wool. And
if you want it to look more like hair,
by the way, you can always go into this
clumping. And when we turn it into a
mesh, you can make those hairs thinner
by just making the radius thinner, which
of course if you do that will involve
re-baking. Now the question is, what do
we do for the shader to really make it
look like hair and then make that look
better? Well, all I need to do is add a
set material node, which will allow me
to pick a material. I'm going to make
one called hair for example. This should
be inheriting the hair material. The
object itself can have a different
material which I can call object.
They're going to be very similar in
color but using a different BSDF. So
this one's going to be using the object.
And now we are in shader land. First of
all, I'm going to take my object and I'm
going to make it more like a yellowish
sheep skin. Something like that. That's
going to be very rough because it's
going to be the skin that's underneath
all this stuff. It shouldn't be very
reflective. And just so this is more
visible, I'm going to get rid of the
background which is looking nice. But
there you go. And the difference here is
instead of a principled BSDF, I'm going
to use a principled hair. So even though
this isn't a hair particle system,
there's nothing stopping us from like
using this. So principled hair. I would
recommend using the melanin slider cuz
that's more intuitive. So I'm going to
get rid of all the redness. As you
decrease the melanin, it's going to be
like kind of like graying, whiter and
whiter and whiter. So this is white
hair. Somewhere around here should be
blonde and then all the way to black. So
just pick a color that you feel like
represents the thing. Back in the
object, now that we know what color this
is, I guess we can edit it to be a bit
more saturated to match. just so I can
see the or rather not see the boundary a
bit better. And that's pretty good. I
mean, really all we need to do is like
change the distribution if we want so
that they're not uh they don't have bald
spots. Although I think that actually
adds quite a bit of something. Maybe in
the roughness, which you can think of as
how fibrous is this. Maybe uh take the
roughness, bring it up so it kind of
looks more like dirty hair that got wet
at some point. Maybe also the same with
the radial. I'll be honest, I don't know
much about this BSDF, but that's
definitely looking like kind of wet wool
to me. Especially as you zoom in, you
see it's composed of curls. And now we
can control this quite nicely. And I
should mention kind of the one that I
was using I made in a live stream cuz
I'm doing Nodevember every single day on
the default Cube channel. So far, this
is what I've made for the prompts. I'm
going ham. It's taken two to four two to
three hours every single day. I'm going
to make the final kind of perfect blend
file available on my website
cgmatter.com. Again, if you want free
nodes, go there. You don't need to be a
member. But if you do want to be a
member and get years worth of project
files, then I would recommend joining.
There's more every single day. There's
160 of you, close to 170. The only thing
I would do beyond this that I did in the
live stream so you can check it out is I
distributed a bunch of points again and
those represent where these clumps will
kind of converge. This is the one I
made. Very similar process except I
didn't use instancing. I used the for
each zone that I modified to look
substantially softer and I did
compositing. So you can check that out
and hopefully you learned something.
Goodbye. See you.